[Music]
all right guys
bang bang i've got marcus here thank you
so much for doing this
awesome great to be on your show for
sure let's just jump right into your
background you're obviously building a
really incredible company today but what
did you do before and how did you get
into technology
i spent about 15 years in finance
everything from consumer finance for you
know in consumer banking in europe
um also in africa and southeast asia i
spent time in investment banking i spend
time in private equity
um and again across multiple markets a
lot of it i lived in singapore for most
of the last 15 years i've lived in
you know i was born in south africa so i
spent you know these 20 years in africa
and then also in europe so
a lot of consumer banking investment
banking capital markets
um and then of course in across all
these different geographies which
which i think kind of led me eventually
to you know doing something in the in
the crypto space because you know it
takes a bit of
you know when you know what the existing
system looks like um i think you have
you you many ways a lot more in awe of
of what this new financial system can
potentially do for us
absolutely and maybe let's just start
with kind of what was the original
impetus for the idea for me now
we in about 2013 i i quit my finance
career
and i said ways you know what since
childhood i wanted to do something in
tech
um and you know i said where's the best
place in the world to start a day
company and that was in my viewing palo
alto so i actually
moved to palo alto uh rented a house
from an early
square employee and i had a guy that was
actually an african fintech
entrepreneur come and stay on my couch
for a couple of a couple of weeks he
didn't have place to stay
and he actually introduced me to bitcoin
for the first time
and i think you know like a lot of
people say you know you almost have
these
multiple aha moments i think when he
explained he was a software engineer he
explained a lot of the technical stuff
to me and that was a big aha moment
i think it was only a while later when i
you know the first time i actually sent
something you know with bitcoin i
remember there was someone in indonesia
who
had their skype window open and i i just
scanned the person's qr code and it shot
through to
um indonesia pretty much instantly and
that was a massive massive aha moment
for for me as well
um just out of interest when we you know
so that was the impetus in terms of look
this is going to be big it's about
moving
value across the internet what do we do
with this where things got interesting
is we originally said look it we don't
you know it has to do with money and
value and surely the banks are going to
be interested
and so at the time when we started me
and my co-founders you know we got
together and we
decided to build these things for banks
now bear in mind this is 2013. this is
the wild west days of crypto we've got
mountbox we've got
you know silk road and we at the time
actually built a crypto system fully
integrated for africa's largest bank
where you could actually log in with
your customer details of this bank
you could buy bitcoin we started
installing it into the atm systems
you could send and receive it similar to
how you would use a mainstream kind of
crypto product like we have now
and we announced that early 2014 in
london at finovate
and you know i remember i was standing
on the stage then i had to slide up and
it had the bank's logo and it said
bitcoin and
as soon as that slide went up people
started getting up and taking photos and
all hell broke loose
and you know in a good way because you
know a lot of banks all of the world
started phoning us
and asking us okay hold on are we
missing something here
but then also the particular bag got a
bit stressed out because they had so
much media attention so they
kind of publicly backtracked on it and
said look you know it's just a pilot
we're not rolling it out but the reality
was it was live on this system
uh we built this in conjunction with the
banks compliance teams and the central
bank in in south africa that at that
point
so so you know we took about the next
year
working with a lot of big banks on a lot
of problems right how do we solve
inter-bank settlements how do we make
you know trade finance better all these
things
that you you know at some point so
quote-unquote blockchain companies
trying to do
and to make a very long short story
short you know we we came to two
conclusions
through their process the one was the
banks were going to take 10 maybe 15
years to actually do something in the
space where customers can actually use
it
and we also realized at the time look
you know for better or for worse the
best use case
of a blockchain is a decentralized
cryptocurrency
and so a lot of this blockchain stuff at
the time didn't make sense and so what
we then eventually did
is you know we had a lot of banks that
build this for us or experiment on this
but we said look there's consumer demand
we've already built something that is
genuinely robust from a security and a
compliance point of view
let's just launch our own consumer
products on top of
this platform and so we went straight to
consumers and we you know we built what
we now have is our
you know crypto wallets to just make it
easy for people to buy and sell send and
receive and for intense purposes
building a consumer version of a
of a global you know uh crypto bank and
and that started about 2015. so we've
had a few you know
um changing direction along the way but
it was a very valued
valuable experience for us and of course
it also helped us build a lot of
relationships and gravitas with a lot of
regulators and banks throughout that
period which has really helped the
consumer business a lot over the last
few years
absolutely i want to talk a little bit
about emerging market financial
infrastructure before we kind of get
into the solutions right so
some of it is good some of it is bad uh
maybe walk us through your evaluation
and even if you want to break down
certain markets as to
how people should think about that
emerging market financial infrastructure
sure that's a that's a good question you
know the
i think the most important thing is you
know it sounds like an obvious thing but
we have to
recognize that emerging markets is a
very very broad category
it's like saying the americas or you
know
the northern hemisphere there are so
many countries in emerging markets
and they are all so so so different so
even within africa or within southeast
asia you know
the difference between malaysia and
indonesia is massive the difference
between nigeria and south africa is
massive
now again we all know this
intellectually but i find that
you know it you almost forget it if
you're not careful even for us that you
know we have a massive presence in all
these markers that if we're not careful
we start thinking that people are going
to behave in this
you know in a similar way so i think you
know recognizing that up front
and knowing how to build a business or
at least you know target customers in
all these markets
i think is you know that that's the
that's the um
you know key important thing i think you
know
broadly in terms of you know trends you
know for us emerging markets really is
africa
southeast asia or eight you know that
would include you know
india as well and then there's north
asia which is china
japan uh korea we don't really blame
those markets
what we've seen just again like
generalizing a little bit
but you know southeast asia tends to be
a little bit ahead of the market than
africa and we've seen this with you know
mobile adoption we've seen it with
e-commerce
and so on so what you know and crypto is
a good example there's a lot of stuff
happening in asia both being built in
terms of consumer adoption
that's really encouraging but it's still
you know three or four years
ahead of where we see that same kind of
cycle in in africa
the other thing i just say is you know
there are you know a couple of other
misconceptions
i think about some of these emerging
markets which you know i think is useful
to know about i think the one is
you know this this is one example
everyone loves talking about
beza right whenever people talk about
fintech and emerging markets it's in
base and pesa now
the beta is a very unique story of
something that happened in a particular
country at a particular time
but that's not been replicated broadly
across emerging markets certainly
not across you know africa in fact it's
failed many many in many many other
countries right and that was
you know the short version of that is
just there was a company with a lot of
market power that just introduced a new
product and everyone started using it
it's a bit more nuanced than that but
so i think you know it's easy to latch
on to
one or two success stories and then just
assume everything else that we do is
going to be like that whether you're
normal
fintech or whether you you know the
crypto side of things
and i think that's that's important and
then the last
i guess important thing is you know in a
lot of these markets
it really the problems are around
distribution it's not a product issue
you know if i if i had you know one
satoshi for
you know every company in in the uk or
the us that phones me you know once a
month
you know twice a month and says we have
this amazing new technology
it's going to really help you know solve
all of africa or southeast asia's
problems
um please can we you know can we put it
on luno
and then i go oh but why you know why
why should we be involved you know
you've
built this amazing thing because they
don't have distribution and so a lot of
the cool stuff that
even in our industry that people are
building whether it's around use cases
for remittances or investments or
you know online e-commerce and so on
they are great ideas with a huge
potential but you have to get to all
these people and it's very hard to get
to all these people
very very we are dealing with low trust
environments
it takes a long time to build this trust
not just with the consumers themselves
but also with the regulators and the
banks and all the other
you know stakeholders and so you know we
we
have to be smart about how we take these
technologies and take it to the market
and you know not you know i don't want
to say don't be overly enthusiastic i
think the enthusiasm of the crypto
community is probably
one of his strengths but there is a bit
of a reality check on how we need to
go go about doing some of these things
but again it will be very different by
country and by market how you build that
trust and how you
how you kind of distribute those
products absolutely
and so talk a little bit more about this
idea of the balance between
technology and distribution right and i
think that it's a very
interesting um and valuable framework
for people to understand because
just like in the early days of the
internet we saw a lot of people who
built some amazing technology but it
might not have been as user friendly
as it needed to be they might not have
actually had the distribution that they
needed so
how do you think through that kind of
balance between the technology
innovation and the distribution actually
in people's hands again very good
question i think
you know if you look at certainly on the
consumer side if you look at most
consumer companies
in you know certainly in the tech world
they are
mostly successful because of their
distribution at least from
from the data i've seen there are some
exceptions now of course
you know i think it's important to know
there is a minimum level of
quality that you need for a product
right like you you know if the product
needs to keep people's money safe it
needs to be people's money-savable if it
needs to be able to send something from
a to b it needs to be able to do that
but at some point and and i think it's
also you know what
when markets start maturing and when
competitions start speaking up
the distribution part of the equation
becomes a lot more important so i think
in the beginning like crypto is a good
example in the beginning it was all
about product
because they were generally issues you
know there were risks that you know
you're going to say oh we you know we
some crypto company and it's really
exciting and you know buy your crypto
with us but then it gets stolen the next
day right that's a problem so you
solve that with building really good
products and i think you know the crypto
industry and for a lot of kind of the
larger players
we all have to be you know
we have to acknowledge that a lot of the
growth and the traction we've seen
in our industry wasn't because we had
the most amazing products it was because
the media wrote about crypto
the whole time and if the media are and
i'm talking more like 2017-18
um cycle now if the media are writing
about it the whole time
and there's no competition i mean at
that stage there was very few places you
could buy bitcoin even in the us
and most other markets people are gonna
you know go to your platform and it's
gonna create this illusion that you've
built a product that is just so amazing
that you never even have to think about
distribution
i think we are way beyond that point now
i think the next cycle so there i would
say you know the right thing was 80
product 20 distribution but that is
going to swing over the next few years
and i think it's going to be the
exact inverse of that where as long as
you have the minimal minimum level of
product quality
it is going to be you know distribution
where the game is going to be one
certainly from a competitive point of
view
the the the last thing i just mentioned
there is well and
you know again very pertinent for a lot
of people in our industry right so
you know remittances fantastic use case
for crypto
i'm i have no doubt in my mind in the
next 10 or 20 years crypto is going to
form the basis of
you know most global remittances and
it's going to be
completely transformative for people and
for countries and
yeah but if you were building
a remittance crypto remittance product
today or over the last few years
you need to understand that the product
you know just the fact that it's being
moved with crypto
i don't care if you're using the
lighting network or whatever i mean
we've built many products like this
you know previously your competitors are
the wasted unions the transferwise the
remittance of the world
and because they are distribution
companies and so they built those
distribution channels they built those
brands
because consumers are not going to care
how the money gets moved as long as it's
just
you know it moves and unless you have a
massive price advantage which you don't
have at the moment because there's not
enough liquidity in these markets to do
it
so it means that when you are building a
company you have to not understand what
company you are building
if you are targeting remittances you are
building a remittance company
which means you are going to have to
raise capital to compete with remittance
companies
that have raised hundreds of millions of
dollars that have licenses in all of
these markets
it doesn't mean you can't win it doesn't
mean there's you know there's not a
you know a business to build there but
you have to understand the game that you
are playing and then you are
90 playing a distribution game whereas
you know when you're in the defy side of
things at the moment that's more
productive because we're not at
that level of competition on that on the
on the consumer side
when the distributions are again yeah
and i think what's really really
interesting
is um this is one of many myths in the
emergency market uh
space right it's kind of this idea that
if you just build it they will come
obviously that is not true and
distribution is king um
talk a little bit about some of the
other myths that maybe people in the
western world
um have about these emerging markets
right there's all these narratives that
kind of
float around and so which ones are
accurate and maybe which ones are
maybe not so accurate so look again i'll
generalize for emerging markets because
we're going to see various
you know varying degrees of this across
you know particular countries i think
the one
certainly in our industry is this thing
about people don't trust their
governments
in emerging markets right oh they trust
they don't trust the government give
them bitcoin and then they're so happy
the problem in emerging markets is
because so many people trust their
governments that's actually
that's the big problem because that's
why the presidents keep on
you know all the governments that are
corrupt in you know keep on
getting voted in because people actually
think that they're helping them
now it doesn't mean that no one you know
everyone trusts the government there's
going to be some segments of the market
you know people that are
maybe you know highly educated or have a
lot more disposable income or maybe we
lived abroad
of course there's going to be you know
you know double-digit percentages of
people in every country that don't trust
the government
but the mass market the critical mass to
keep governments in power and they 100
trust the government and they love the
government because the government gives
them social security
you know some form of welfare they you
know that's what they grew up with
so that's a big misconception and i
think you know that is to rely on that
to say oh people will shift to
crypto economy just because they don't
trust the government i think that's a
bit naive
it doesn't mean that crypto can't play a
really strong
role in starting that shift now so
you know even even uh something like you
know just educating around how money
works that's a really powerful thing
that bitcoin has you know i said i
remember many years ago
i said to someone you know if if the
whole industry just collapsed tomorrow
and the only thing it did was educate
people about money it's a success story
massive success story
and so you know just you know laughing
about people playing around with
dogecoin and things like that i mean
these
if if the purpose is to educate in this
value in it and so in that sense i think
yes definitely we can we can in emerging
markets change that but it's going to
take a generation it's not going to
happen in you know two two or three
years
the other one you know i think that
that's maybe worth just also talking
about is this ib
inflation every country with you know if
there's hype inflation everyone's gonna
run to bitcoin
um if you know if the currencies are
depreciated now again
on a macro and a purely intellectual
level
that is true right if if they are if
there is going to be you know a lot of
these markets the currencies aren't
strong
um and people are looking for
alternatives i can tell you now that
that alternative
typically is us dollar and after that it
might be gold a little bit
and in a you know way after that is
something like bitcoin
now we we've seen in some countries not
necessarily with this ip inflation but
with these
you know real big depreciations and
currencies we have seen increase in
activity
of people buying crypto and then of
course we speak to our customers and we
you know what i know what they're doing
and and some of them are genuinely doing
you know they're buying it because they
want to hedge against the currency or
they want to put it somewhere else it
does happen but it happens
in a very very small amount of cases and
certainly if it's people with a lot of
money they don't put all of their money
into that right again they're going to
go mostly to us dollar
maybe some gold and so on but the but
the other interesting thing a lot about
a lot of these markets are because
they're trying to control their
currencies is that you know they don't
allow you to just buy u.s dollars some
countries outright ban it other
countries make it very difficult and so
i think you know that's also where
there's this interesting opportunity for
stable coins
you know to come in into play which you
know it might be that in some markets
that's the
intermediate step people have before
they actually start using the other
things but
yeah it doesn't mean that in these
economies people don't buy crypto to to
deal with these issues but it's it's
it's not nearly as prevalent as for
people you know
at least publicly say it or wanted to be
of course i wasn't wanted to be like
that but that's not the reality that
we're dealing with not yet it will
you know over time we will get there but
again we're like 10 years away from that
how important is it that uh the emerging
markets maybe
10 years ago 15 years ago there wasn't
as much internet penetration there
wasn't as much
uh kind of cell phone smartphone
adoption today that's changed
drastically
is that playing a big role in kind of
the adoption we're seeing in some of the
emerging markets
yes that is definitely true right the
the i mean
it is internet penetration is going like
crazy people have multiple mobile phones
i mean just to give you an example in
south africa where we you know
have you know run the biggest crypto
company in south africa
about 80 of our users only use their
mobile
which is a big big number um other
markets would be a lot lesser in the uk
you know maybe be half or even less and
so
that is definitely not a misconception
and it's happening and it does
actually sew a fertile ground for people
to be using these type of products and
services that are kind of mobile first
um to use them a lot a lot easier and
that you know that
kind of cliche about african africa
leapfrogging other technologies
i there's something true in that as well
right it doesn't mean that we go from
someone that have that's never had a
bank account to
putting all their money in crypto i
think that's a bit of an extreme jump
but does it mean that they are you know
going to be sitting around
you know a table with their friends and
everyone's going to be you know doing
things on their mobile phones and
be keen to try new things a little bit
and share things uh
very social driven you know markets
where people share a lot of what they're
doing and products that they're using
definitely so it is gonna i think i
think it's gonna definitely accelerate
the adoption
but you know with a lot of these
technologies they always say that you
know it's always happening you know
faster when
than you know when some people want it
to be and slower than other people so i
think we we just need to find that
middle way but
that's a big factor that's that's going
to be you know driving a lot of adoption
a lot faster for sure
yeah and what do you think the biggest
opportunity so like the
in terms of these emerging markets and
understanding you know each market is
different but what do you think the
biggest opportunities are for
technologists and entrepreneurs they
really do want to make an impact they do
want to
uh kind of affect change is there
specific things that you're saying
look this is an unsolved issue or this
is the area that i think more people
should be paying attention to but
they're not yet
yes i think look they i think there's
two two parts that are
kind of the big kind of pla areas where
the
the the work needs to go into and where
the opportunities lie the one is
unfortunately a little bit tricky and
that's around regulation
you know we've again it depends on the
country we've seen some countries like
malaysia
you know look that they very forward
thinking in terms of how they think
about technology and financial services
and
you know we we spent a couple of years
working with with their government and
regulators
to come up with essentially the first
properly
you know licensing regime in emerging
markets which they issued and
you know 30 companies applied and you
know we we
we have their license now and operate
legally in malaysia so
you have examples of that but they're
few and far between in a lot of
countries
in particular in africa you know the
regulatory regimes are not adequate for
not just for crypto but for mass market
kind of consumer
finance products it's not because i you
know
i'm not sure if it's because people
really don't want it to be like that
it's just the markets have not evolved
like that
and you know there's just not been the
economics of you know activity to
support
bringing a you know another bank or
another challenger bank or a crypto
company into the into the market so a
lot of the work that we are doing
and and other companies in the space as
well not just and other funding
companies is on the lobbying and
regulatory side
how do we create an environment where
people companies can actually flourish
like
there's no you know in the u.s and and
in the uk
you can apply for a challenger bank
license you can
become a payments i mean it's very easy
to become a payments company or
remittance company
in a lot of these countries those
classifications don't even exist
so so that's a problem for fintech
generally the good news for crypto is
that because they don't exist
as long as the regulators are pragmatic
and open
they are it presents opportunity to
create new legislation that's specific
to crypto
because one of the worst things i think
that can happen in the industry in
crypto
you know globally is that people are
forced into other licensing regimes that
don't apply to crypto given how unique
you know the industry so i think that's
where a lot of the work goes in and then
you know the second part we briefly
covered on is around
you know we call the distribution but
you know we can rephrase that as
building trust
in these markets and you know if you
know if you are a highly commoditized
product or something that's purely
you know product that's purely focused
on price like uber is a good example
right like it's just you know how cheap
can you i mean it's how hard is it to
get into a car and drive somewhere just
how cheap can you make it relative to
something else right
there's not i mean there's a little bit
of trust required to get into the car
but it's not
you know that's not i wouldn't say
that's the main problem that they're
trying to solve
with with people's money you know people
are very strange about their money and
that you know the trust equation is very
complex and again depending on the
country
or the type of product you are going to
have to do something that people can
actually trust you that they you're not
going to steal the money that you're not
you know the thing's not going to
disappear and so on
and that's where most of the work i
think is going into certainly from our
side and
and you know where i think most of the
work should be going into is that how do
you build trust
in these markets whether you know again
starting all the way from education
to how the product functions to where
it's available
to how it's co-branded with you know
things that people already know
that you know and that's the opportunity
because if you can build trust in these
markets
you can you know that that trust you can
leverage so broadly
and you know again if you look in china
or indonesia like some of these super
apps right where people use one app and
they trust that thing so much and now
you can put anything into that product
you can
you know people start with car sharing
and then the next thing they have
financial services and you know you know
texting and whatever so
that trust is so valuable in these
markets again given
they are generally low trust
environments but once you cross that
threshold
then then you have a lot to to work with
and that's i think the biggest
opportunity for any company whether
you're crypto which is kind of a general
consumer company
in tech absolutely i want to talk a
little bit about
you mentioned kind of regulation but an
aspect of regulation i've been thinking
a lot about is centralization versus
decentralization and
is there uh any sort of bifurcation
between the developed world and the
emerging markets in terms of how people
are receptive to decentralized products
versus centralized products
uh and do you see maybe some of the
more adversarial regulatory regimes
almost
making it default that we need to have
decentralized products in order to
allow people to be onboarded without um
the governments being able to kind of be
egregious in their law making so
so i can you know i can tell you that
from an emerging markets perspective
if you ask me about like singapore and
and the uk and so on i can you know i
can tell you
you know a certain answer but for most
of emerging markets
we that convers we we like two years
away from that conversation
we are literally still trying to explain
to people what bitcoin is
that's it i know you know and you know
decentralized finance versus
centralized finance all of these things
it's you know we
these are things that from a consumer
perspective is interesting especially if
you're an early adopter in the crypto
space and maybe in some kind of more
advantage right through regimes or
somewhere in new york where you know the
bid license was issued many years ago
and now
you know you're starting to have
conversations about these other things
um
but it's not even on that agenda not
even close
right so so i think we you know we still
at that early stage
what i can say is what where regulation
where the big pain point is you know
originally with with a lot of regulators
around aml
and you know anti-money laundering and
so on right and that obviously is just
kind of a generic
risk factor but in emerging markets what
a lot of people don't realize is these
countries have capital controls
now if you grow up in the us or the uk
you might not even know what that means
but it means that you can't just send
your money in and out of the country
freely
in some countries you completely
prohibited in some countries there's a
limit
on how much you can send in and out but
in almost all cases you need to actually
report how much
money you send or receive now
i think we all know given where the you
know financial technology is going
is it's going to be really difficult for
governments in the next generation
to have effective capital controls at
some point those things are going to
break
and you know whether it's because of
bitcoin or whether it's just because of
globalization
or you know countries you know
competitive advantage it's going to be
very hard to hold
on to those things forever but the
unfortunate reality is where we are now
and certainly for the next few years
those are the rules of the game
in a lot of these countries the and the
risk for them is using
crypto or these kind of products to move
money in and out of the country now
again the reality is people are not you
know we have a lot of data that we can
see
you know what people are doing with the
crypto because it's obviously all on the
blockchain and
we have a lot of visibility and it's not
actually a major problem
but there's a perception that it is a
problem or that it could become a
problem
in the future and that's where almost
all of the energy is going on at the
moment and if you see some of the kind
of regulatory reactions around the world
of regulators in emerging markets if
they're not positive
then it's usually because of this factor
so yeah so
i i don't think there's there's much
else to add there but on the
decentralized
point i think you know they they
they they the ones that that know a
little bit i mean decentralization is
obviously kind of a broad topic but this
you know if i could throw peer-to-peer
crypto trading
maybe just i know it's not really
decentral you know
decentralized but it's it's it's in that
direction right at a very basic level
if you look what the regulators in
malaysia did they said look
you are not allowed to buy or sell
crypto in malaysia unless it's with a
company that's a regulated
business and they specifically
do not allow p2p transactions now can
they control it
probably not or they can you know try
and make an attempt
but they are very overtly saying that
that is something that they don't want
to happen and so they are looking to
have some kind of central oversight into
something now again
you know the market's still really small
let's see where it ends up in a couple
of years maybe that conversation has to
be revisited
but i suspect that once we get over the
basic you know capital control issues
and what is bitcoin issues
when it comes to that it's not going to
go down well with with most regulators
certainly not in emerging markets
absolutely and i guess part of this too
is uh the constant cat and mouse game
right between the technology and
innovation
uh kind of getting ahead of regulation i
forget who told me at one time but they
were like
we don't want i think it might have been
uh uh
tony thomas who was a former four-star
general
who said you basically don't want
regulation to get ahead of innovation
because then you're innovating
to the regulation right you're basically
only doing what the with the government
and politicians and as we know they
might not be the uh
the most groundbreaking uh thinkers um
and so i think that that's a
pretty interesting way to look at it i
want to bring this back to uh luna which
is what are you seeing
from growth in specific markets and and
uh also within the product suite itself
what are people doing
right what do they want to use which
products are most interesting to them
which markets should people be aware of
that seem to be growing the fastest
so so yeah what you just mentioned
reminds me you know
about six or seven years ago we were
sitting doing some training for a big
central bank and a bunch of regulators
and there was a guy
sitting behind me from one of the
regulators and he was in his late 60s
and he'd been working there for like 30
years and we were explaining
bitcoin and dark markets and blockchain
traceability and i i just remember the
guy he was talking to his colleague and
he just said
i i just i didn't sign up for this you
know like what it's just
i don't have i want to retire in a
couple of years like you know i don't
have time to try and understand this
thing because it's just i just want to
you know relax and do my job and not
have to deal with this
and so you kind of have to feel a little
bit for people that are you know
now having to basically relearn an
entire new you know industry
um but yeah so so certainly i so i i
agree with you on that i think
you know um it you know there is a lot
of education work that we do obviously
as
a company and an industry where we try
and lobby and we try and educate
um and and what i can just say about
that before we go into the
you know kind of the the markets and the
opportunities is
generally speaking the regulators have
been surprisingly pragmatic
we've had a few exceptions obviously you
know every year there something happens
and there's you know someone's
communication or someone but generally
it's been
it's been pretty good and what i've also
you know every now and again
strangely that i hear in these
regulatory conversations is that people
say oh but you know
look at you know look at what airbnb
that look what uber did now
those are completely different not
incomparable companies compared to the
risk of you know what we're doing in
terms of financial regulation but i
think
that's kind of just stuck in people's
heads that like technology is yeah
you know the world's going to change and
and you know at some point we're going
to have to just deal with this right so
so what is happening and and you you
obviously know this but
the de facto regulators in our world
has actually been the banks because the
banks are the ones that are saying look
if your product
depends again on the type of product
that you have if you have a kind of a
fully decentralized product it's it's
not
it's not relevant but if you have
something where for example in our case
you have to deposit money into our
account
we need a bank account and they will set
the rules
they will say you have to do the aml kyc
and so on obviously you know we
self-regulate but that you know the
regulator
isn't really guiding everyone and the
problem is that a lot of financial
institutions are just
de-risking generally speaking right it's
not about a lot of people like to say oh
look that banks don't
don't want to work with crypto companies
because they're scared of what crypto is
going to do that's not the reason right
they scared of getting fines
for remittance clients non-profit
organizations you know crypto somewhere
in that kind of high-risk category
and so that's kind of been the issue and
you one would hope by now would have
been sorted out given how you know
prevailing crypto is
and and at least the you know the the
the macro narrative is obviously changed
to be a lot more positive
but it it still continues to be a
problem across the world developed
markets and
emerging markets you still see banks
cutting off accounts
um you know and and that's that's a big
big challenge
um but just yeah just on the on the
on the opportunity side and the markets
to watch
i think the you know certainly the big
ones in
africa on nigeria and south africa they
are
by far the biggest markets by any
measure in terms of population gdp per
capita all of those things and
and the crypto kind of trading volumes
and and that kind of
reflects that as well um and in
southeast asia the markets to watch are
malaysia and and indonesia um
philippines to maybe
some extent but it's not as you know
maybe as big as one
one would think um and then of course
singapore is you know
uh just launching their kind of new
licensing regime a lot of crypto
companies are moving there to to
work under that license so i you know
we're expecting some big things from
singapore as well but
you know in terms of what people use it
for you know it's it's
i would say a couple of years ago it
would be very similar to someone in a
city in
the us for example it's someone that is
educated
has a bit of extra money and so on
and so that has been traditionally the
demographic they
they certainly are people that use it
for transactions right so
so we we also integrate into e-commerce
systems and so we you know ran
for over 10 000 merchants i think that
and we could see people buying things
online it was very small but it was
happening
but people do use it to move money they
use it to move money in and out of the
country
and you know from from what we can see
when they do do it it's not because they
want to circumvent capital controls it's
just the convenience is a lot
easier than having to go through all of
the process of declaring the money and
filling in all the forms and so on so
um yeah so but then you know even to
this day i would say it's less than ten
percent of total volumes
there are transactions the rest is
broadly into this category of
investment so that could be you know
seeing it as a store value or seeing it
as you know some kind of asymmetrical
return or even speculative trading right
the one thing that is changing those
over the last you know 18 months
is that that kind of investment group
where it's people with a lot of
disposable income and so on that's
starting to move into the mass market
and into that longer tail
and you're starting to see the people
that will eventually probably
benefit the most from crypto are
starting to come into the crypto
ecosystem but it's a it's a very
uh recent thing it's it's not it
certainly wasn't like that for the last
six or seven years but that's the
exciting part right so we're starting to
to tap into that market now
yeah and so when you think about um kind
of the future prospects of what you're
building
uh you guys obviously recently did a
transaction with dcg
maybe talk through a little bit as to uh
what the logic
behind that was kind of why you guys
were excited about it and then whatever
you can talk about in terms of how the
business will change or the structure of
luna going forward
thanks john good question i think look
we you know we
love what we do we love building you
know what we
perceive as really really good value for
our customers and the
you know the opportunity to impact you
know not
millions or tens of millions but
billions of people with our product
is you know it i i don't think there's
any doubt within
you know our team and and and that you
know that's what we can do
so the idea of like selling the company
has actually never been
top of mind um i know a lot of people
used to say oh but you know what is your
exit strategy it's like i've literally
not thought about it so and we've had
some acquisition offers over the years
many years ago as well
and you know we people talk to us and we
say look you know luna
we do things in a way that we think is
best for our customers in our market and
we don't want someone else to come
kind of spoil that spoil that but you
know dcg what maybe a lot of people
don't know is dcg was our very first
investor
barry you know barry silbert and when we
were you know
four or five people sitting in a room
building that initial product for that
big bank in africa i was on the phone
with barry regularly just talking about
crypto talking about our business and so
on so
it's been seven years that i've worked
very very closely with dcg
and the and the one thing that we we
realized as the market started maturing
and as it started growing is that
you know you have to ask yourself what
is the best business model like what is
going to be
you know from from other than just
building products that your customers
love
what is from a company point of view
going to make the most sense because we
are going to see
massive increase in scale we are going
to see consolidation in the market we're
going to see all of these things how do
you position yourself for that
and and the thing that i loved about dcg
always other than just
being very culturally similar and
knowing them really well
is that they if you look at what they do
you know again a lot of people think
that they just do crypto
investments but they that's not really
their main business they own and
operate some of the biggest players in
the space genesis
you know crypto trading and lending um
grayscale which is now the biggest
you know asset manager in the space
so so so they have these these these
groups of people that really focus on
particular segments of the market and
particular problems
and the one part that was kind of
missing there was mass market consumer
or retail
if you want to call it that and
obviously dcg is a little bit more u.s
centric and we very international
so it kind of made sense if you think
from a business model point of view like
okay but you know what is the best way
to succeed in this industry and i
honestly think
it's by allowing teams to focus on doing
the thing that they do really well
too many crypto companies are trying to
be everything to everyone
that is okay in a very mature industry
if you 100 years of banking and you want
to consolidate to get some cost
synergies that strategy will work
it doesn't work when you're at the
beginning of an industry and everyone's
still trying to figure out what actually
to build and
what is the best value proposition for
whatever segment of the customers that
you know it happened to be and so for
that reason just dcg have a unique
unique business model
if we could be part of that i think it's
just purely objectively speaking the
you know the best business model i would
love to be part of that they have a
massive balance sheet behind them and
they have a 20 30 year time horizon i'm
thinking through this there's no
you know they're not a public company
they're not
under pressure to do things in the short
run and let's be honest
you know as excited as we all are about
what's happening in the crypto space
right now
this is a 20 or 30 year project and so
so for all of those reasons it made
sense for us to to to to be part of that
group and
you know the easiest way i sometimes
just explain it to people is
you know instead of having seven
shareholders and four board members and
i have one shareholder and one board
member but it
just happened to be my favorite one so
that works very well so we run
completely
independently nothing's changed and we
know other than the scale of our
ambition and our access to capital
um but yeah that's you know we you know
it's
it's business as usual um in that sense
we all operate completely independently
yeah
makes a makes a ton of sense what is the
one thing that you're looking forward to
uh moving forward
it might not sound like the most
exciting thing but you know
this this thing about buying your first
bitcoin
that's a problem that's still not
actually been solved in most markets i
you know i could you know in our
industry and if you can take and finance
okay sure you kind of know what you want
to do
but you know i can walk out of this
house now and i can walk into a
restaurant
with 10 random people at a you know at a
table and i can ask him
go and buy your first bitcoin and i can
assure you
that none of them have heard the word
luna coinbase
blockchain i mean they wouldn't even
know like do i go to my bank do i go to
7-11
is it online is it offline i mean it is
completely completely
you know early stages in our industry
and so
a lot of what we are doing over the next
12 to 12 to 15 months
is continuing to address that problem of
like where do people just go the first
time
all the way from the you know the the
the brand top of kind of mind brand
building and education
all the way through that funnel of being
able to trust you with their money and
being able to get kyc properly and
and so on so again it doesn't sound as
sexy as
um as defy uh or a few other projects
but it's an
important problem that's not been solved
and it's a crucial
problem for us to solve to enable the
rest of the industry right if there's
not a critical mass of people that are
using bitcoin or buying and selling it
all of that infrastructure that we're
building and all of that liquidity that
we are
creating in all of these markets enables
other companies to then come and build
on top of that and say okay well now i
want to do remittances
if you know there's a lot of liquidity
in nigeria and
you know countrywide now the product
will actually maybe
work right so so i think that's where a
lot of our attention is going on and
something i'm still very very excited
about seven or eight years into the into
the journey
um but on top of that we're gonna be
launching a couple of new markets we've
got a lot of demand in a few other
markets but yeah we haven't announced
too much around that but i'm sure
uh you will you'll hear more about that
and i'll also i mean i'm
i haven't been spending that much time
on fintwet in the last few years but i'm
i'm
i'm making a comeback and um yeah we're
gonna be posting a lot more on twitter
around
updates on all of these markets what's
happening on the ground in nigeria
what's happening on the ground in
indonesia
um and and hopefully that will be useful
for people to to to
to to kind of get a better idea of
what's going on i love it
before i wrap up i always ask everyone
the same three questions so the first is
what is the most important book that
you've ever read
if i actually didn't know that these
questions were coming so
the most important book i've ever read
i can i just i'm just starting a little
bit for time here but just so you know i
have a bit of an obsession with reading
books and i i buy about five books for
every two that i read so
so i i just need to also think that if i
actually read the book
um
i think
yeah that's like asking what is my
favorite child right it's just
impossible but okay
i'll just be i mean a fictional 100
years of solitude
gabriel garcia marquez really amazing
book
um i know there's a hundred business
books but you know i'm gonna i'm gonna
pick that one out for
for now so yeah that's a great one
second one is a little bit more personal
your sleep schedule so i used to be
somebody who slept only for you know
five or six hours
uh and then i recently started to uh to
work with
um and invested in the company eat sleep
uh and in that business
uh they've got a thermo-regulated bed
essentially you can make it really hot
or you can make it really cold i sleep
literally on an ice cube and you sleep
like a little baby now what's your sleep
schedule and how has that changed over
the years
same as you you know i did investment
banking right you don't sleep
other than maybe under a desk every now
and again um
and and i changed my schedule to go to
bed early i
now try and get like seven or eight
hours of sleep where i used to do you
know four or five i tried to wake up at
the latest six i've tried the five 5a
everything a little bit it's a bit
tougher than it sounds
but yeah seven or eight hours um go to
bed very early
complete game changer and can i just
this this
um this sleeping company you mentioned
i am absolutely dying to get their
product in the uk i can't find it so
if there's a way if someone i can talk
to someone can ship me something i am
really keen to do it
you know i'm all in on the sleep thing
now that's something that i've
i've seen you know and read about
extensively so really really keen on
that if
there's a way to get it we will uh we
will work on it for sure
uh last question is a little bit more
fun and you get asked me one to finish
up
uh the last question is about aliens are
you a believer
or a non-believer
i am actually a believer i you know just
basically but just
on you know statistical odds you know
from a beer
you know that that's why you know i
don't believe because i you know i think
i going to see one in my lifetime but
just statistically speaking i'm pretty
sure there's live somewhere else
in the world i tend to agree with you
uh i don't know if they've come to earth
but uh but i definitely think
that they're out there somewhere where
are they there maybe well maybe
they sent us um sent us bitcoin
um in in you know from the future you
never know
absolutely uh you could ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
i'm gonna ask back what your favorite
book is i know maybe it's a little bit
boring but that is a really good
question and it says a lot about a
person when you ask that question so
yeah so i mean look i i always say the
same three books which is rich dad poor
dad richest man in babylon and thinking
girl rich
just because they were kind of
life-changing for me uh a book that i
recently read that i thought was really
good was
morgan housel's the psychology of money
um or
or also um uh the
uh if it wasn't the uh almanac of naval
ravicon
uh which is just basically a bunch of
naval's thoughts all put together
everything both those are great books as
well so i'm similar to you i could go on
and on and on and just you know
a hundred books and uh and feel like i
didn't uh do it a good service that's
fine
very good ones right um awesome well
alyssa marcus i really appreciate you
taking the time to do this where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or find more about luno
now is luna.com um the twitter handle is
luno global and my twitter handle is
mark swain you'll find it through the
through the lunar handle as well
got it uh well listen thank you so much
for taking the time to do this we'll
have to do it again in the future
awesome thanks so much for your time